tonight we're gonna be talking about a
subject that I've just seen personally a
lot of club play are struggling with and
that is end games in which you have a
queen or you just have a pond and
there's a part of the seventh rank
that's about to promote so sometimes
depending on the situation it's a win
for the person with the queen they can
prevent white from promoting and and
then just win the game and sometimes
it's a draw so we're gonna go over the
cases and try to understand the
difference when it's a win one it's a
draw so we'll jump over to the board
here really quick and there's a couple
cases that are simpler so we're gonna go
ahead and have a look at them first in
the case of pawns in there okay the
night pawns so the B pond and the G pod
it's almost always a win for the
attacker the person with the Queen same
is true with the middle pawns so if
you're if your opponent has a pawn on
any one of these green squares chances
are it's a win for black there's the
really strange exceptions where that's
untrue but as a general rule these are
just always a win for black so we'll
take a quick look at this and this
should be a win now more difficult are
the outside pawns the row cons on the
AMH file and the bishop ons so the CNF
pawns and for those it depends on the
position of the black King so we'll look
at where the King needs to be in order
to have a winning position so I think in
this lecture you should be able to
immediately assess a scenario like this
and whether or not it's a win or a draw
so obviously if you're white in this
position you're you're hoping to draw
because black at any moment can sack the
Queen for that pond and it's a draw so
black is playing for two results he's
the one that wants to win now what kind
of breeze through the simpler ones so
here we have a jeep on
and the basic technique that black needs
to use is he needs to check the King
around a lot and whenever the King ends
up stepping in front of the pawn black
has one turn to advance the King to the
pond so for example this is a game
Ernesto in ER keV versus Peter Kuryakin
and so here's how this game finished
okay
the Queen has to get closer and for
example we'll look at in the game King 7
but for example if they just willingly
played King g8 well no problem
we just advance our King and then
whenever he moves away we check until he
has to go back in front of the pond
again King g7 is sorry King g6 this is
basically the same and I want to
introduce this idea to in general in
most of these positions that we're gonna
see tonight it's a good idea for black
to not only just check I mean checking
is fine there's a lot of these there's
just gonna be several ways you can win
but attacking the queening square
usually forces white to make a very
specific move so it's one of the most
forcing moves because if he moves
anywhere other than h7 in this position
if he moves here for some reason you
just put your queen on g8 and okay now
it's now it's easy you can spring your
king in and win the pond so by attacking
the queening square you're sort of
forcing him he only has one move which
makes it a lot easier to calculate and
here for example okay we can pin and now
a common pattern how do we force the
King in front of the Jeep on
Queen age five and the King has to go in
front of the pond
okay then we advance our King and this
will be a similar pattern so you can
memorize a pattern or you can just you
know sort of understand the idea the
idea is just to put the king in front of
the pond and go from there
so here's how the game progresses he
attacked the pond so the king has to go
back and defend it and the Queen
advanced all the way up all right and so
here black just needs to force the king
in front of the pond so you can do so by
attacking the pond from really really
close the only place you can go is here
to protect your pond and a simple check
and here's where the game ended so this
was the actual game and the reason it
ended is because white knew black had
the technique so it's been like 30
minutes for us but like one minute for
you so whenever the King goes in front
of the pond just to repeat and we got
some new faces here so that's good
and the King approaches and you just
apply a similar pattern so we just need
to force the king in front so normally
the best way is to pin the pond and just
check them in front and you'll notice
it's just the same pattern over and over
you check and then you put your queen
really close to the pond and okay but
here there's a really quick way you can
keep doing the same pattern but there's
a quick win here for black so here I'll
test the audience and this is a little
trick that we're kind of going to see a
lot of this lecture King g5 which allows
me to Queen
yes so we can do this again this is fine
okay this is fine but there's a an even
faster way on this cuz yeah I mean you
can check you do this again you know you
can do it again but there's a quick win
here King age five exactly a very
interesting move
and this happens very often these are
the kind of patterns you need to look
for in these types of positions you can
even allow white to promote in many
circumstances because it's hopefully we
all see it there's a big checkmate Queen
h6 so that's the kind of thing that is
gonna happen all night you don't have to
be setting up mating that so you
anticipate they promote but then the
next move or the next couple moves it's
checkmate so that's when it's night
pawns it's a pretty simple hopefully so
here let's see
so this is the game magnus carlsen
versus alexander gerst took from the
world blitz championship in 2009 and so
now we're gonna look at the central
pawns which to repeat because it's been
a long time for this class and there's
new people if the pawns are night pawns
or central pawns let's make them green
until they're yeah prince a nice color
because those are the pawns you want to
see as the attacker with the Queen
because those are almost always a win so
this is a winning position for white and
the treatment is the same the goal is to
put the King in front of the e pawn and
then slowly advance your King until
you're able to either take the pond or
get a checkmating attack so we'll go the
way Carlsen did it then we'll go back
and see sort of a slightly more refined
way his way was fine he checked a lot
and went here and so and we'll see if
when we'll get the same pattern we can
get there a little bit faster by instead
going to f4 this is just a slightly
faster more accurate way to do this
now you go here which again so we're
right by the pond that's what you where
you want to be he's forced to go here
and now what moved his way play
the king okay which was checking of
Queen H Street
okay yeah I can go here I guess you can
do better
yeah why not coming after check
excellent
Queen f3 so you can move away from the
pond and let me have it which okay you
have to play this if you're trying to
still win but now we get to simply
advance the king okay now he goes here
many ways to win
what's the simple moves I guess pin it
let's see this also wins this is
everything wins with the idea that if
you go here white can play what how are
you gonna let them promote again yeah
King day three and yeah what a funny
position yeah and checkmate good so yeah
again it's that technique the
alternative is to go here and here okay
this also wins and so for most of these
there's several ways that you can do it
but okay for central pawns and Knight
pawns it's the same thing you just want
to get the king in front of the pawn but
we'll move on to some slightly more
difficult more challenging exercises it
worked okay now for another little trick
we're gonna start looking at the bishop
ons so bishop pawns and the outside
pawns these are a bit more difficult but
once again we'll have a look at a
similar little trick this is Valerie
popov versus T Margaery of 2002
so I'll just the class was the winning
move here for wait
yeah so you can sew here yeah you can
you can start doing checks and get the
King in front of the pawn there are some
tricks that we'll see in the next
exercise when it's a bishop on but here
you have an immediate win and this is
the sort of it's not really a tactic but
it's the sort of move meaning attack
that you kind of really want to be
familiar with so that's why I'm going to
show it just one more example like
things 1-squared too far away okay so
what what happens here in a position
like this is where black wants to be and
this is kind of an interesting fact
about the position which side does the
king want to be on there's actually a
difference does I want to be on the long
side or the short side and for stale
mating tricks the king wants to be on
the short side the reason is and we'll
see this in our next exercise sometimes
we have steel mating tricks based on the
fact that king can go to h1 and if the
Queen ever takes on F 2 would be
stalemate so that's what we're gonna see
so this might win but again there's a
simpler knockout blow
you don't want to lie to promote but you
want to let it promote if you checkmate
them yeah then you don't care yes let's
see if you can calculate a similar thing
okay you don't think don't think moving
the kingís fruitful I mean so for mating
threats I mean the queen can't do it by
yourself you need the King closer
there's doesn't matter what Square you
can teleport that doesn't matter you're
gonna need the King involved for a
checkmate okay you'll go here which is
okay which is the same I guess I looked
at this move it's the same okay I
promote just give me one more turn I'll
check and trade the Queens and alright
I'm the best
checking ways
check on the way they don't get checked
immature so this is a very important
trick so that's why I'm showing it and
this will be crucial to solving all of
the rest of the puzzles going forward
because they're they're suddenly gonna
get a little bit harder here the way
they move here and if you haven't found
it at home you can pause them and keep
looking is that the surprising move here
fill King III and remarkably black does
not have a good move you know if you're
not moving you're if you move your king
I'm checkmating you if you you know move
your queen I'm checkmating you there's
no good check remarkably black just
doesn't have a good check this this
doesn't work this doesn't work it just
doesn't work none of these checks work
so you got all these all these possible
places you can check me but none of them
work no matter what black does he's
gonna get checkmated very soon so this
is an important little trick so we'll
look at it just one more time here and
this is a silk that's the sort of thing
they're looking for you want to get your
your King really close and also the game
actually went like this and then he
resigned because he's gonna go down and
then the game's gonna go to e3 anyway
but uh okay if they promote we're so
close and because they're actually so
close and the Queen is working with us
there's no checks for black yes so it is
a pretty well-known technique so this
will be the kind of thing that hopefully
we're taking note of because it'll
affect the rest will be lecture okay now
here's a case where again it's a bishop
on this is the game Rafael Lube sinski
versus Mateos Bartel I'm not gonna
pronounce any names right but this here
is actually a very easy draw for white
assuming he knows just the one little
thing he needs to know why don't we use
know one thing to draw that is whenever
he gets checked just bounce back and
forth in the corner so here the king is
just too far away if the King were
closer and we'll look at how close he
needs to be in the next exercise
then it might possibly be a win for
black like if I'm Way up here then black
has a the ability to win the game but as
it is here's how the game panned out so
the white the black queen can get as
close as she wants all right fantastic
but in this position the obvious
stalemate trick and this is what makes
the bishop pawns a little bit tougher
than the other pawns this would be
stalemate which actually happened that's
how the game finished but obviously you
don't have time to move your King
because white promotes and that would be
a draw the King is just way too far away
and so the fact that you have this
Bishop on gives you these still mating
tricks when the pond is on the G file
and it's a knight pond then you don't
really have these tricks because the
King is tucked in the corner in a way
that he won't be able to get himself
stalemated and the central pawns lose
way too much side on both sides so the
stalemate tricks just don't work but uh
we'll see when the pawns here there's
some still mating tricks because okay
those whites turn here it's still me
sure so right so you don't you want to
go to the I file
you know you wish there was one more
file because then you could do the same
thing and then I take your pond at
stalemate but this is not enough space
so you're not gonna get stalemated if
you're here I can play a move by Queen
h6 and force you in front of your pond
as we saw in the last last couple of
exercises here so okay so that's sort of
the simple drawing technique that white
keeps in mind is this so we're gonna
talk about the king and the placement of
the defending King so the king as we've
discussed wants to be on the short side
that is the side closest to the corner
some people call it the right side the
correct side whatever you want to call
it just the king wants to be on this
side for that same stale mating trick
and okay and we're gonna look at it's a
little bit different it's the black king
doesn't need to be as closer
I guess the attacking King doesn't have
to be as close if the King is on the
wrong side or the long side and I'm
gonna highlight some magic squares here
so I told you guys before the though I
heard we talked about some magic squares
and here are the magic squares when this
is only when the King is on the short
side and this is just some chess
geometry that is very interesting so the
pawn diagonally from the potting square
so okay here's but here's the pawn you
go light square to light square this is
a square that if the black King is one
square away because you're on the short
side then the short side is just one
square away you have a wind
conversely if this King is over here one
square away from east seven it's a win
and so that's okay just a pawn directly
next to the other
right right yeah so there's like a
little little box you you have to be in
yeah I don't know what you guys might
kind of like to call it those and even
though some of the squares are
impossible so if you're in that box it's
a win for black so this is a draw this
is a draw this is a draw this is a win
this is a win you know so wherever you
are
if you're in that box one square away
from either the square next to the pond
or the square diagonally from the pond
and we can kind of understand why g6 is
an important square for the king to go
to because in many lines when you
promote and you're we can force your
king to the h-file
and we need this square for some mating
drinks you know so imagine if I was here
I could check you on the H file and then
Queen h7 so it's for mating attacks or
if I'm on the seventh rank my queen will
be able to swing over to h7 and
checkmate you so that's why this is an
important square and this is the game
Jose Soros Musquin low vs. Arthur you
suppose and there's more than one way
that black can win this and he chose the
prettiest because he's a chess artist so
I really like the way that he did it
there's two techniques
the easy way and then the pretty way so
when you really want to show your
opponent's you know what you're doing
you do abusive pop style in this game he
went to g6 we'll have a look at it
perhaps the easy way a principled
continuation is Queen e7 and points move
is forced he kind of has to go to g7 if
he goes here we step up and so again we
can see why this Magic Square is so
important for black okay so instead he
goes to g7 so little more testing but
white is basically in subs wine here you
know the pawn is pinned the king is
gonna have to move away and give us
access to the queening square so I would
probably go here I chose b7 because
sometimes I check you you're still
pinned you move away if you don't go
here then you want protect your pawn or
going
your pond and both of scenarios are bad
for you so he goes here
but now king g6 and yet doesn't matter
you can make a knight if you're a wise
guy but King h6 and then the game ends
and yes obviously queening is the same
checkmate
but I want to show you the way that in
this position he chose to win king h6
he's gonna promote let's check oh is
this sound loud enough I've been signed
it's not here yeah but people have
headphones on at home so I don't wanna I
heard their ears too much one more time
oh oh so let's go back in g6 so this was
correct yeah this is nice
right and wait a minute that clean is on
the magic square so that doesn't work
for us we don't want stemming okay
berries dude so in the game Queen f6
okay
and we go to the magic square
it has black blundered this looks pretty
good for white looks pretty good for way
just check on e6 in game over yeah
excellent and so here this would just
when she moved the King there's a
checkmate on h7 you can block with your
queen and that obviously they just go
very quick checkmate so what yeah let's
just look at this because maybe it'll
come in handy later in the lecture
so back in this position is a very
interesting maneuver you can check check
so notice where the Queen is it's right
behind the pond this what makes this
maneuver work so the King's on the Magic
Square
the Queen is directly behind the pawn so
that when it promotes you can check and
check on the h-file
or votes on the other side of the board
the a file doesn't matter okay very good
so this is I just made this one up it's
so it's basically the same thing except
for last the audience again what are the
magic squares that the black King needs
to be one square away from in order to
have a winning position
g6e seven so it's the same the diagonal
pond from the pond and the side with a
short corner here and directly next to
it yeah yeah I assume there's some
brilliant way I could say okay this is
the geometry so it's diagonal towards
the short corner side okay just in front
right yeah so it's in front is this in
front which way is in front from whites
perspective still which ways in front
memorize this geometry is I think if you
play Tetris and you're right all night
shaped like night shaped yes diagonally
behind you think this way is behind his
wife on so it's fine okay so Weiss yeah
behind on the diagonal or just directly
adjacent okay they can figure it out at
home we can figure it's just yeah just
figure it out so here obviously we're
within our one square radius that we
need and again that only applies when
the King is on the short side here so
this is a win for black but by no means
super easy and again there's several
ways that you can win this position so
we kind of understood why g6 was a magic
square because it that's a good square
for our King because we can make you
when your king is in the corner but
what's so special about a seven
now we're gonna incorporate a seven into
our our attack here so there's there's
several ways to do it
I guess one way is to check and the good
thing is so here you probably won't mess
up with your kinga's clothes but uh okay
you can check if they go here but okay
so we can go here give the White King
some space and then checkmate okay
similarly we can also win in this
position by pinning this also will win
no matter what he does if you go here we
can check and it's the same sort of
thing we can go here so something like
this will be a Czech mating attack for
black so okay those are the two squares
hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense sure and for this it's actually if
you want to practice you can just move
the king and queen wherever you want and
see for yourself you know see if you
can't win with maybe I'm maybe I'm wrong
maybe you guys can prove me wrong but uh
you know put the king here and your
queen wherever you want put the king
here just you know you can play around
with it as much as you want you can even
go on an endgame database if you want to
just move it around and test this out
for yourself so you can either just
believe in the magic or you can just
figure it out for yourself let's
calculate and all right
what
but here the King is on the wrong side
or if you prefer the King is on the long
side or the wide open side call it
whatever you want whatever makes sense
to you guys so the King is on the long
side which is wrong he wouldn't much
rather be here and this is also kind of
important if you're on the defending
side say your king was here and you were
trying to decide
what move to make assuming you you
couldn't promote which side would your
king rather go to well now you know you
want to go to the short side so because
he's on the wrong side and there's not
stale mating tricks over here because he
you want to get in the corner for his
dominating tricks it'll actually take
black some extra time to get into the
corner for his little trick which means
now the magic squares are once again di
sorry once again the square behind
underneath below the other diagnosis so
naughty too so this is the difference
now it's two squares and the white king
only needs to be two squares away from
either one of these squares for it to be
a win for white so yeah now everything
is to this this pawn is still in the
same place this is the same magic square
but the pawn directly adjacent now is
two squares away and the White King only
needs to be two squares away from either
of these magic squares so this all wins
that's two squares and then since I'm
teaching both classes we have ours and
ours we're just gonna make pretty
pictures I think for the second hour I'm
just gonna like paint on chess face and
look at this all the squares light up
they'll probably need the next 60
minutes so okay the White King is two
squares away and this would be a draw
draw anywhere in the red is a is a win
so why should this be the case okay
what's in here also - there's another
little technique that in general is a
the right way to do this as white we do
not want the King to run this way this
way yeah we don't want to go to h2 eater
we don't want the King to run this way
because then he's gonna have steel
mating tricks in the corner
so a good way to do it there's many
checks but if you just pick I don't know
some normal normal check these probably
both win but you're it's going to be
more technical than it has to be if you
decide to skewer at the king and okay
there's two squares you can do it it's
again it's just in general you just
skewered the King to the cleaning square
this just always seems to work out in
most examples so it's just a good
technique to try to find always skewer
the king to the cleaning square and it
prevents him from going that way and in
order to win this position we're going
to need to centralize our Queen we're
going to find out that the Queen needs
to be on the second or third rank and
the king is gonna have to be on the
Magic Square so let's have a look
we need to centralize again we don't
want the King going this way so another
good check and we put our reign in the
center and okay so black is trying to
run to the other side
that's time to bring the king end all
right we're one square away and with our
clean centralized here we're doing
pretty good
so now we're on the third ring that's
where we want to be want to be on the
second or third ring the reason being
this is where our King's gonna be so on
the second rank whatever that you can
let them promote and then you can mate
them on h2 and if when you're on the
third rank you can do the use of palm
the new over that we already saw it will
pretend like he's the first guy that
ever came up with that maneuver that Oh
that'll be a win so we can check that
out as well okay inviting you to take
the pond and stalemate them but no so we
remember how the Yusupov technique
worked where did our queen need to be
I was like ten minutes ago yes I'm
looking at you where did the Queen need
to be we needs to be on h6 so before the
black pawn promoted I said this is where
you want the Queen and this is where you
want the King and so to repeat if and
okay you can there's other ways to do
this that might be easier but this is
the prettiest so that's that's important
you really want to show them not only do
I know this in and out okay I find the
prettiest yes exactly
yeah so the Queen wants to be directly
behind the pond and the king wants to be
on the Magic Square
so here again we we have it the Queen
directly behind the pond the King on the
Magic Square so when they promote
there's the the same checkmate what's on
a different part of the board so
everybody is confused on the h-file and
yeah again you either move over and get
checkmated or give up your Queen and
achievement so that's the first example
of King on the wrong side or King on the
long side which or whatever else you
want to make up so here again the king
is on the long side so who can tell me
where are the magic squares
G 3 and D 2 so the square
aiming towards the corner the diagonal
towards the corner from the pond or two
squares away because again it's it's two
squares away when the King is on the
wrong side okay
so is this a win whose turn is it it's
white to move so what's the evaluation
here you stay win good because you're 2
squares away so you're inside this magic
box so since he's inside the magic box
it will be a win for white so just one
square way and it would be a draw
what is a five-night count be five
councils so we're in the magic box so
this should be a win for white okay and
here there's actually only one move for
white queen a six good and okay we're
preventing the King from running over to
the long side and again skewering the
kings of the queening square basically
forces black to play his only move if
you go to some other square well we can
just plop the Queen on the queening
square and then that's quite simple we
just bring our King in and when your
pawn so blacks move is basically forced
but in the other example we were able to
bring the Queen to the center by
checking and then going to the center
here that's not gonna work and this can
happen a lot in these types of end games
that your own king can be in the way so
we can't do it exactly the same way as
we did before so we're gonna need to
find a different way of checking the
King and preventing black from going
over to the other side
please c4 so if you don't check me I
promote and so this will be at draw your
king is obviously not close enough to to
make me on that journey clean e6
excellent so it's sort of the only
realistic check but let's be careful
which which way he's black gonna go he's
obviously I'm running well if he goes
the other way
well he doesn't want to go that way he
wants to go here because if I go here
then you you weren't here with the first
lecture we're right needs on the short
side the magic squares are here and the
King has to be one square away so in
this position if this King we're on g2
it would be a draw so this this needs to
be prevented which is a big game so
there's actually three moves that win
here and everything else blows over
what's that
Meeny Ford okay now this is a draw I'm
on this side and now the magic squares
are here and the White King is not one
square away from the magic squares yeah
queen g4 and okay any any one of these
squares on the G file wins this seems to
make the most sense because you want to
get as close as possible to the king and
again you're forcing him to go the other
way
alright it's still not easy so you can
keep checking or you can bring the King
end King's not close enough but here's
I'm not I'm not close enough since he's
on this side here's the magic squares
and so if I'm two squares away from
either one of these then I'm close
enough so I'm close enough okay
inside of the bringin Kinkos or between
directly behind apply if you go here
what are they gonna do they're gonna
promote
between age 3 again what's he gonna do
he's gonna promote we need for you want
to repeat this
uh-huh
now you want to go here
okay so now since I'm on the short side
the magic squares are here and your King
needs to be one square away and it's not
so this is a draw
but this is right so don't ya don't let
me go this way yeah Queen h1 that
prevents me from going that way alright
I go here
so we kept the king over on the long
side and okay we're looking for mating
tag right queen g2 is correct
keeping the pond pinned and so the other
example we saw Queen on the third-ranked
is a is a win so we're gonna understand
why being close to this square is
important here because now obviously if
they promote checkmate so that's that's
the importance of the d2 squared
it's for the Queen when she's on the
second rank so this is what you need to
get the Queen on the second rank and the
king close enough to the Magic Square
while keeping the King on the long side
yes
so we already yeah I mean so a lot of
people are coming in late and this whole
lecture got delayed a whole bunch
because a huge emergency at the Hall of
Fame so don't even work there but I
saved the day yet again yeah everybody
add some applause Bensimon come on does
that make sense to everybody they can be
rather tricky
all of these these exercises so just to
repeat one more time when he's on the
long side and I know people just keep
coming in repeating you guys have heard
it a thousand times hopefully some of
you at home understand since he's on the
long side he your king needs to be two
squares away from either of the magic
squares which in this case it's the the
same as we've seen before plus the
square two squares
adjacent so that and so by keeping the
King away and forcing him to stay on the
long side we were able to get our Queen
to the second rank and get our king just
close enough so that we could use the D
2 square we will now take a look at the
game struck here are
etienne back row from 2008 we're not
gonna pronounce a single name right
that's that's fine we get this position
so lastly we're gonna look at the rook
pawns these are probably the trickiest
of all these are the worst
so the magic square for the rook pawn is
a little bit different does anybody just
know I've topped their head if this is a
win or a draw it's a win no wait no it's
a draw
it's a is it both the possible win so
right so again these are really hard to
assess but if you know the magic squares
which we just make a diagnosis of dark
square upon the magic squares are the
two diagonals so you can make these
little boxes in your head yeah so the
white king needs to be within two
squares of f2 or g3 in this case and if
not so this is a draw so again we can
draw another box because we got all the
time in the world been signed it'll cut
out however much he wants but we got
plenty of time yes that's a tough one to
see so don't forget about e5 at home
that's that's the important one but I
can see it's a nice little box and the
king is not in there so in this game
they just are stalemate didn't even try
because presumably 27-hundred know this
presumably moving on
hello everybody well I'm glad you asked
what if the King were on d2 great
question
how is he winning so now again we draw
the dark-squared little little thing
soever you want to memorize it
that's how I remember it he could also
be like oh that's too much ASA and one
behind her however you want to do it
it's just the two darts squares here
you're here it would be the two light
squares a little triangle however you
want to memorize it and here the king is
in within two squares of the magic
square so this is a win for white but
how is the question it's a good question
let's take a look so again it's the same
principle that we've kind of looked at
before of skewering the King to the
queening square still a good idea
so Queen d7 my next check I think do you
want to be really really far away and
I'm trying to get my queen closer to
your king it probably wins it must wind
but I don't know I'm trying to get my
queen closer to your king okay so you go
here you're about to promote can't like
you promote so check it's a similar
thing we skewered the Queen and then we
again a check and then right here you
get to centralize the Queen so that's
the big thing the Queen and all these
lines needs to be centralized in order
for your attack to work and the question
is do we need to apply any more checks
or do we bring the King a little bit
closer
needs to be closer
okay so
cleany one okay
okay and they promote so yeah we have
good control over this square and now so
this the point of the first one to will
be kind of to understand where we need
our pieces to be some people are
starting to figure it out
same thing is before but now you're on
the edge file excellent though finding
the most accurate move here very
difficult unless you understand where
your queen needs to be and for this will
actually keep her on the fourth rank and
we'll see why now if here if here then
queen g4 will be the same sort of
position that we're trying to achieve we
need to check and get the King here if
here there was a make more now in this
position we have what move King f2 and
again no good Queen moves you're
absolutely helpless here as black so
just the same is okay sometimes the
Queen can be on the second rank you also
can be on you know the second file from
the edge which is the G file so one more
time one more time just repeat skewered
we got the Queen to the center and then
we can bring the King in and we
intentionally leave her on the fourth
rank this this wins but you have to like
repeat a little bit and then get to the
same position so we checked and we got
the Queen to the second file from the
edge and we brought the king so the king
lands on the Magic Square and black has
helped us so let's check out one more
okay is is this a winner at draw it's a
win to scores away from the magic square
though they were green how do I know
it's yellow this is a win because okay
we're two squares away but now we're
coming from the other side on the h-file
and mate on the second-ranked very
interesting would anybody like to make a
first move here yeah maybe seven each
skewered the king to the cleaning square
okay excellent me and b1 excellent so
it's the same exact thing all right
the queen is centralized now what are
you gonna do I'm looking in yeah exactly
all right I got bleep yes
yes where where are we trying to make
the black king Sanji three you want to
checkmate down if it's not here you want
to check me that way alright that's
pretty well said that makes them that
makes enough sense so uh okay so what do
you want to play here okay excellent
okay
also again we could have gotten lead in
in one lisaknott and then draw
so yeah it's obviously you would repeat
ticket the draw you want to straight
Queens you'd like repeat a lot what do
you say we need to check very good
yeah excellent King g3 yes and again
black is just totally helpless it
doesn't matter what you do maybe this is
the best move is ever better move okay
last longer yeah but yeah so again this
is a totally the way to do it we'll look
at this one more time because these are
quite complicated we did a little
skewering and got the Queen to the
center which again is very important the
next step is to bring the King one step
closer then we have to find the way this
time it's we can see a way to do it
along the second-ranked here so we
checked our Queen into position now
she's on the second rank and the King
comes down and no good move for black so
here the game is over so but uh thank
you guys for watching at home hopefully
that that helped a little bit and if you
like this go ahead and like share
subscribe